>> Greg: HERE WE ARE.
ALL RIGHT.
HAPPY MONDAY, EVERYONE.
I HOPE YOU HAD A LOVELY BIRTHING
PERSON'S DAY.
I DRESSED IN DRAG TO GET HALF
PRICED MIMOSAS AT BRUNCH.
IT WAS WORTH IT.
BUT OTHER PEOPLE, WHO I CALL
JERKS, WENT TO A JUDGE'S HOUSE
TO PROTEST ON BEHALF OF
ABORTION.
SEEMS LIKE AN IRONIC THING TO DO
ON A MOTHER'S DAY WEEKEND, CHEER
FOR ABORTION.
WHICH IS WHAT HAPPENED.
A MOTHER LOAD OF MANIC HYSTERICS
SHOWED UP OUTSIDE THE HOMES OF
U.S. SUPREME COURT JUSTICES
SATURDAY TO PROTEST THE REPEAL
OF ROE v WADE.
REMINDS ME OF AN OLD JOKE.
HOW DO YOU GET A BITTER LEFT
WINGER OFF YOUR PORCH?
PAY FOR THE PIZZA.
SO HERE'S MSNBC'S NEXT DEMOCRAT
CLEANER UPPER WHO MOON LIGHTS AS
PRESS SECRETARY RATTLING OFF
SOME ANSWER AS SHE PRE TENDS TO
STILL GIVE A CRAP ABOUT HER
CURRENT JOB.
TRIGGER WARNING YOU'LL SEE RED
AFTER HER ANSWER AND IT WON'T BE
HER HAIR.
>> YOU THINK THE PROGRESSIVE
ACTIVISTS NOW PLANNING PROTESTS
OUTSIDE THE JUSTICE'S HOUSES ARE
EXTREME?
>> PEACEFUL PROTESTS?
NO.
PEACEFUL PROTESTS IS NOT
EXTREME.
>> ACTIVISTS POSTED A MAP WITH
HOME ADDRESSES OF THE SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES.
IS THAT SOMETHING THE PRESIDENT
WANTS TO HELP YOUR SIDE MAKE
THEIR POINT.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT'S VIEW
IS THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
PASSION, A LOT OF FEAR, A LOT OF
SADNESS FROM MANY, MANY PEOPLE
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY ABOUT WHAT
THEY SAW IN THAT LEAKED
DOCUMENT.
WE OBVIOUSLY WANT PEOPLE'S
PRIVACY TO BE RESPECTED
>> Greg: OF COURSE, LONG HISTORY
OF THIS SORT OF THING.
LIKE HOW FAR, HOW LONG REALLY?
I MEAN, TO THIS?
>> IF YOU SEE ANYBODY FROM THAT
CABINET IN A RESTAURANT, IN A
DEPARTMENT STORE, AT A GASOLINE
STATION, YOU GET OUT AND YOU
CREATE A CROWD.
AND YOU GET BACK ON THEM.
AND YOU TELL THEM THEY'RE NOT
WELCOMED
>> Greg: I THINK I JUST ABORTED
MY EAR DRUM.
AND WHO COULD FORGET THIS
JACKASS?
>> THEY'RE TAKING AWAY
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS.
I WANT TO TELL YOU GORSUCH, I
WANT TO TELL YOU KAVANAUGH, YOU
HAVE RELEASED THE WHIRL WIND AND
YOU WILL PAY THE PRICE.
YOU WON'T KNOW WHAT HIT YOU IF
YOU GO FORWARD WITH THESE AWFUL
DECISIONS.
>> Greg: HE IS STUPID.
IF I DIDN'T KNOW ANY BETTER HE
SOUNDS LIKE HE'S FOMENTING AN
INSURRECTION.
PSAKI TRIED TO CLEAN UP THE MESS
SAYING SHE DISAPPROVED OF
VIOLENCE BUT NOT HOME VISITS.
I GUESS SHE DOESN'T WANT TO
UPSET HER PARTY'S EXTREMISTS
LIKE THIS ONE AT A CHURCH OP
SUNDAY.
>>
[CHANTING] [BLEEP].
>> I'M KILLING THE BABY.
I'M KILLING THE BABY.
♪♪
>>
THANK GOD FOR ABORTION.
THANK GOD FOR ABORTION
>> Greg: NICE RING TO IT
AMERICAN HAS TALENT.
LOOKS LIKE AN AUDITION FOR THE
OPEN CHAIR ON THE VIEW.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: IT WILL NEED A STRAIGHT
JACKET.
THEY CAN BORROW ONE FROM SUNNY.
MEANWHILE OTHERS SHOWED UP AT
JOHN ROBERT'S HOME DRAWING
IMAGES OF COAT HANGERS IN CHALK.
WHICH REMINDS ME I HAVE SHIRTS
TO PICK UP AT THE DRY CLEANERS.
PROBLEM WITH WORKING LATE AT
NIGHT, THEY'RE CLOSED.
THEY ALSO STOPPED BY BRETT
KAVANAUGH'S HOME.
I GUESS THIS IS THEIR WAY FOR
APOLOGIZING FOR CALLING HIM A
GANG RAPIST.
SADLY THEY DIDN'T EVEN BRING HIM
BEER.
THERE'S ALSO MORE CHANTING
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW THAT [BLEEP]
REALLY WORKS.
AS LIZ WARREN THE NEXT TIME IT
RAINS.
IMAGINE, BUT I MEAN SERIOUSLY,
IMAGINE IF YOUR CO-WORKERS ACTED
THIS WAY.
♪♪
>> WHO IS THAT AT THIS HOUR?
[KNOCKING]
>> YOU'VE GOT TO STOP EATING
APPLES AT THE OFFICE KYLE.
YOUR PRIVILEGE PALLET IS AN
ATTACK ON PEOPLE WITH MES 0
PHOBIA.
>> MESO WHAT?
>> PEOPLE WHO GET TRIGGERED BY
CHEWING NOISES.
>> CAN WE DO THIS TOMORROW?
>> YOU HAVE TO HEAR ABOUT IT NOW
JOHNNY APPLE AGREED.
ALL OF US IN THE 99% AREN'T
GOING TO STAND FOR YOUR BIGOTED
BREAKFAST ANYMORE.
ALL RIGHT?
STOP GAS LIGHTING ME.
I SAW ALL THE EURO CHRISTIAN
SYMBOLISM IN YOUR PRECIOUS RED
DELICIOUS.
YOU HAVE A SWASTIKA.
>> THANK YOU I'M GOING TO BED
NOW.
>> WAIT, WAIT.
CAN I HAVE MONEY FOR A CAB?
>> Greg: DIRT BAG DEBBY.
TRULY A DIRT BAG.
SO THERE'S MORE PROTESTS TO
COME.
THEY'RE GOING TO HIT THE HOMES
OF GORSUCH AMY COMEY BARRETT AND
EVIL CLARENCE THOMAS.
SPEAKING OF THOMAS NEW YORK
TIMES SAID ROE VS WADE WOULD END
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE.
WHICH WOULD BE NEWS TO CLARENCE
AND HIS WIFE.
OF COURSE, IT'S A LIE THAT THE
MEDIA HAS BEEN PUSHING FOR FOR
DAYS, IN FACT ALITO SPECIFICALLY
DEBUNKED THAT SAYING NOTHING IN
THIS OPINION SHOULD BE
UNDERSTOOD TO CAST OUT
PRECEDENTS DO NOT.
BUT THE EDITORS AT THE TIME
DIDN'T COMPREHEND HIS STATEMENT
WHICH IS UNDERSTANDABLE SINCE
THEY READ AT A FOURTH GRADE
LEVEL.
BUT ANY FACTS ABOUT THE SCORE
OPINIONS DON'T MATTER BECAUSE
THEY'RE KIND OF UNEXCITING WHICH
IS WHY THE MEDIA HAS TO LIE AND
SAY THE APPEAL WILL END
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE BAN
CONTRACEPTION OR END TACO
TUESDAY.
IT'S THE RAGE AND ARGUMENT FOR
ADDING MORE JUSTICES TO THE
COURT.
IF THE DEMOCRATS HAD THEIR WAY
THE COURT WOULD HAVE MORE PEOPLE
PACKED INTO IT THAN HUNTER
BIDEN'S HOTEL ROOM.
NEVER LET A CRISIS GO TO RACE A
TRAIN COULD ISSED BY KILMEADE'S
BARBER.
WILL IT WORK?
AS DAYS GO ON OUR DAILY PRESSING
PROBLEMS RETURN, INFLATION TO
THE ROOF, BEING STABBED IN THE
ASS WAITING FOR THE BUS.
FACT IS IT IS IT'S GOING TO BE
HARD TO GO PROTEST ROE v WADE
WHEN YOU CAN BARELY AFFORD THE
GAS TO GET THERE.
NOW I THINK PROTESTING A JUDGE'S
HOME IS ILLEGAL IN ALL STATES
AND FOR GOOD REASON.
THE IDEA THAT YOU CAN USE FEAR
IN ORDER TO INFLUENCE ANY
DECISION IS OBVIOUSLY WRONG.
I LEARNED THAT THE HARD WAY WHEN
I WAS ON DANCING WITH THE STARS.
BUT ODDLY THE MEDIA DOES THAT
EVERY DAY TRYING TO SCARE YOU
WHICH IS WHY TODAY THEIR SIDE
ALWAYS GETS A PAD.
BECAUSE ONCE THEY DEEM YOU EVIL,
THEN ALL LAWS ARE MEANINGLESS.
I MEAN, IF YOU'RE FIGHTING
HITLER THEN EVERYTHING'S UP FOR
GRABS.
AND MAKE NO MISTAKES IF IT'S
MONDAY SOMEONE ON THE LEFT IS
CALLING YOU HITLER.
BECAUSE IF THEY DIDN'T SHOUT AND
SCREAM AT YOU THEN YOU MIGHT
ACTUALLY HEAR THE TRUTH WHICH
ODDLY, FOR SOME REASON, NOW
SOUNDS LIKE BILL MAHER.
>> I LEARNED THINGS THIS WEEK,
BECAUSE THIS PUT IT ON THE FRONT
PAGE, THAT ARE PRETTY BASIC
THINGS THAT I DID NOT KNOW ABOUT
ABORTION.
LIKE, IN EUROPE, THE MODERN
COUNTRIES OF EUROPE, WAY MORE
RESTRICTIVE THAN WE ARE, OR WHAT
THEY'RE EVEN PROPOSING.
IF YOU ARE PRO CHOICE, YOU WOULD
LIKE IT A LOT LESS IN GERMANY
AND ITALY AND FRANCE AND SPAIN
AND SWITZERLAND.
DID YOU NOR THAT?
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
I LEARNED MOST PEOPLE WHO ARE
PRO LIFE ARE WOMEN.
DID NOT KNOW THAT.
>> Greg: AND OBVIOUSLY HE'S NO
PRO LIFER HE'S JUST OLDER AND
SEEMINGLY WISER.
WE NEED MORE OF THAT AND LESS
RAGE.
BUT THE LEFT HAS LITERALLY
FLIPPED AND THE WHOLE POINT OF
THE LEAK WAS TO SCARE THE CRAP
OUT OF THE JUSTICES.
DID IT WORK?
IT'S HARD TO TELL.
THEY'RE WEARING ROBES.
♪♪
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
YES, HIS PRONOUNCE ARE HE, HIM
AND SOMETIMES WHY.
HOST OF SPECIAL REPORT, BRET
BAIER!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HE'S WRITTEN MORE
SCRIPTS THAN MY PAIN DOCTOR.
TV WRITER AND PRODUCER, ROB
LONG!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: THE ONLY THING THAT
STINKS ABOUT HIM IS HIS NAME.
MEMBER OF THE ROCK AND ROLL HALL
OF FAME AND ADVISORY COMMITTEE,
SKUNK BAXTER.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: AND SHE'S LIKE A PAPER
TOWEL THIN, WHITE AND CAN ABSORB
ANY LIQUID.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: BRETT, BRETT, BRETT.
>> Bret: GREG, GREG CONGRATS ON
THE NEW STUDIO.
>> Laura: ISN'T IT NICE?
>> Bret: TREMENDOUS AND WITH A
FIRED UP AUDIENCE.
>> Laura: I KNOW
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: WAY TO PLAY TO THE
CROWD BRETT YOU'RE AN OLD
PROCEED AT THIS.
>> Bret: YES
>> Greg: WE DRUG THEM OR THROW
THEM OUT IF THEY DON'T MAKE
NOISE.
DO YOU THINK THESE PROTESTS WILL
SWAY THE VOTED?
THESE JUSTICES THEY KNOW,
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO CHANGE
THEIR MIND.
>> Bret: I MEAN I DON'T THINK
SO.
I DON'T THINK THAT THIS WAS
FULLY BAKED AND THERE MAY HAVE
BEEN MORE TO IT BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT ANYTHING HAPPENING
OUTSIDE THEIR HOUSE IS GOING TO
CHANGE HOW THEY WERE GOING TO
VOTE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT IT'S
REALLY AN HONOR TO BE A PART OF
FOUR GUYS AND A LOVELY WOMEN
TALKING ABOUT ABORTION.
FOUR GUYS
>> Greg: BRETT, SHE DOESN'T
IDENTIFY AS A WOMAN.
>> Kat: BELIEVE IT OR NOT, I
ACTUALLY DO
>> Greg: WOW
>> Greg: YEAH
>> Greg: BOYS ARE FUN TO TALK
TO.
>> Kat: LIKE THAT, HUH?
>> Greg: SHE DOES THAT ALL THE
TIME BRET, DRIVING ME CRAZY.
>> Bret: IS THIS WHERE I LEAD
>> Greg: YEAH QUICKLY RUN AWAY.
SO HAS ANYBODY EVER SHOWED UP AT
YOUR HOUSE?
>> Bret: YES, YEAH.
>> Greg: IT'S UNSETTLING, ISN'T
IT?
>> Bret: YEAH, AND YOU, TOO
>> Greg: WELL IT WAS YOU WHO
SHOWED UP.
WAS IT GREG THAT SHOWED UP?
>> Bret: I DID BRING SOME
HOMEMADE BROWNIES OR AT LEAST
THAT'S WHAT I SAID.
SKUNK HAS A NEW ALBUM SPEED OF
HEAT COMES OUT JUNE 17TH THE
ALBUM COMES OUT.
>> Skunk: YES, SIR
>> Greg: HALL OF FAME FROM DUBEY
BROTHERS ALSO PEOPLE DON'T
REMEMBER, PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND, ALSO STEELY DAN
AMONG OTHER THINGS BUT NOW A
COMPLETE EXPERT IN MISSILE
DEFENSE SYSTEMS AND BASICALLY
SPACE WEAPONRY.
CORRECT?
AM I RIGHT.
>> Skunk: MORE OR LESS
>> Greg: I'M SAYING WHATEVER YOU
SAY HERE HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE GOVERNMENT.
>> Skunk: THAT'S RIGHT, ALL
PERSONAL OPINION
>> Greg: I DIDN'T WANT YOU TO
GET IN TROUBLE.
DO YOU THINK IT'S PART OF YOUR
RIGHT TO SHOW UP AT PEOPLE'S
HOUSES?
>> Skunk: NO, I JUST THINK
THAT'S WRONG BECAUSE I JUST
THINK IT'S WRONG.
I MEAN THERE'S NO -- THE THING
I'M HAVING A LITTLE BIT OF A
PROBLEM WITH IS I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND ALL THE DEFINITION OF
ALL THIS.
IF SOMEBODY DECIDES TO TERMINATE
A PREGNANCY THAT MEANS ONE
THING, BUT IN 30 STATES IF
SOMEONE SHOOTS A PREGNANT WOMAN,
IT'S A DUAL HOMICIDE
>> Greg: RIGHT, RIGHT.
>> Skunk: SO FIRST OF ALL, MAYBE
DEFINE TERMS FIRST BEFORE YOU
EVEN MOVE TO THE NEXT SECTION.
I UNDERSTAND IT'S A SENSITIVE
SITUATION.
PEOPLE ARE VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT
IT.
BUT THERE SEEMS TO BE NO
DEFINITION, NO BASIS FOR REASON
ON EITHER SIDE
>> Greg: AND I THINK THAT THIS
IS A LOT OF KIND OF A THING
BEING KICKED UP BECAUSE PEOPLE
DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
DEFINITION SO THEY HAVE THESE
ANCILLARY -- I'LL GET TO YOU IN
A SECOND YOUNG LADY.
ROB THE OTHER THING BILL MAHER
SAID WHICH IS INTERESTING IS THE
MAJORITY OF TERMINATED PREGNANCY
ARE DONE WITH PILLS.
ABORTIONS AREN'T EVEN A QUESTION
ANYMORE.
>> Rob: ABORTION RATES HAVE GONE
DOWN OVER THE YEARS SINCE
ROE v WADE BUT TECHNOLOGY HAS
MADE SOME EASIER BUT ALSO ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY I THINK WOMEN
ARE MORE PRO LIFE IS BECAUSE
SINCE ROE v WADE, FOR 50 YEARS,
THERE HAVE BEEN ULTRASOUNDS.
ULTRASOUND TECHNOLOGY IS MUCH,
MUCH BETTER.
THEIR IDEA OF WHAT THAT IS
INSIDE THE WOMAN'S BODY IS A
MUCH MORE COMPLICATED FEELING
THAN IT WAS IN 1972.
BUT LOOK.
>> Skunk: HELPS DEFINE IT A
LITTLE BIT.
>> Rob: AND COMPLICATE IT,
RIGHT?
BUT LOOK, IT'S LIKE, WE KNOW
WHAT THEY THINK ABOUT THE IDEA
OF GOING TO SOMEONE'S HOUSE TO
SCREAM AT THEM TO GET THEM TO
CHANGE THEIR MIND.
THEY'RE AGAINST IT.
BUT THEY'RE NOT AGAINST IT WHEN
IT'S FOR SOMETHING THAT THEY
LIKE.
SO THIS IS JUST PURE HYPOCRISY
BUT THE IRONY ABOUT THIS ALL IS
IF YOU READ THE ALITO OPINION HE
ALSO AGREES HE SHOULDN'T BE THE
GUY TO DECIDE.
THAT'S THE WHOLE BASIS OF THEIR
OPINION IS IT SHOULDN'T BE US
WHO DECIDES IT SHOULD BE THE
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES WHO LIVE
IN A REPRESENTED DEMOCRACY AND
THAT'S HOW THESE THINGS ARE
DECIDED.
THEY HAVE A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
SCREAMING ON THE SIDEWALK SAYING
NO, HOW DARE YOU NOT ENACT YOUR
UNELECTED POWERS THAT YOU DON'T
THINK YOU HAVE.
IT'S SUCH A STRANGE, SUCH A
BIZARRE -- IT'S LIKE EVERYBODY
NEEDS -- INSTEAD OF ARGUING AND
SCREAMING ON THE LAWN THEY
SHOULD GO HOME AND READ THE
CONSTITUTION OR TAKE AN ONLINE
CIVICS CLASS AND EVERYONE WOULD
BE MUCH HAPPIER.
THIS COULD BE THE BEST THING
THAT COULD HAPPEN.
>> Skunk: SUSPEND THE LAWS --
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
THE DEFINITION THING IS DRIVING
ME NUTS
>> Greg: I THINK EVERYTHING
SHOULD BE DECIDED BY ME, KAT.
RIGHT? IF IT'S GOING TO BE A
WHITE MALE WHY NOT IT BE ME.
WE IN -- WHO DECIDED FIVE WHITE
GUYS.
>> HERE'S THE THING.
THERE'S A HEIGHT REQUIREMENT
>> Greg: OH.
>> SORRY.
I DON'T MAKE THE RULES
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, KAT, CLEAN
IT UP FOR US.
TAKE IT HOME.
NO?
>> Kat: IN WHAT RESPECT
>> Greg: I DON'T MEAN LIKE IN
THE KITCHEN CLEAN IT UP OR TAKE
IT HOME.
INMEAN THE TOPIC.
A SEXIST WOULD SAY
>> Kat: YEAH, I THINK IT'S A
SEPARATE ISSUE, RIGHT?
PERSONALLY I AM PRO CHOICE IN
THE SENSE THAT I DON'T THINK
ANYONE ELSE'S DECISION TO HAVE
AN ABORTION HAS ANYTHING TO DO
WITH ME OR IS MY BUSINESS AT
ALL.
I THINK WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
COURT, THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
LEAK THESE DECISIONS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO HAVE
PUBLIC INPUT AT ALL.
AND I THINK IT'S A BAD LOOK TO
BE OUTSIDE OF ANYONE'S HOUSE IN
ANY CIRCUMSTANCE BECAUSE IT
LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE TRYING TO
INTIMIDATE THAT PERSON, WHETHER
THAT IS TRULY WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO OR NOT IT CERTAINLY LOOKS
THAT WAY
>> Greg: WHAT IF YOU'RE STANDING
OUTSIDE SOMEONE'S HOUSE AND
HOLDING A BOOM BOX
>> Kat: THAT IS ACTUALLY THE
WORST KIND BECAUSE THE ONLY
REASON SOMEONE DOES THAT BECAUSE
YOU HAVEN'T ANSWERED THEIR
CALLS.
>> THESE EUROPEAN COUNTRIES THAT
WILL MORE RESTRICTED LAWS IS
BECAUSE THEY VOTED ON IT.
THE LAWMAKERS MADE THE LAWS AND
THE PEOPLE ELECTED THE
LAWMAKERS.
IT'S INTERESTING WHEN YOU GO
THROUGH THE JUSTICE SYSTEM IT'S
ONE THING.
WHEN YOU PUT IT TO THE PEOPLE
IT'S ANOTHER THING
>> Greg: AND WE'LL HAVE TO STOP
THERE.
VERY, VERY SMART.
VERY SURPRISING FOR BRETT TODAY.
INSULTED ME, THAT'S WHY WE LOVE
EACH OTHER.
THAT'S HOW YOU KEEP OUR MARRIAGE
STRONG.
UP NEXT ELO